the Joe Rogan experience do you think
we've ever been visited by aliens mm-hmm
yeah Thank You Elliot walk amongst us
Natick coming in coming in see how
stupid we are and go back and tell these
stories and [ __ ] you think so I mean I
can only see why I mean if you thought
there's no way we're the only people in
this whole universe there's no way this
only happens one time in this one part
so it's got to be somewhere else and I'm
pretty sure they way you're headed as
far as technology and you know what's
the other word progress innovation yeah
all that yeah way [ __ ] yeah so if they
gather know they gather be they gather
look at this it only makes sense yeah if
we could stay alive for a few thousand
years longer than we are now
I mean imagine how much technology we
would have by then and who knows what
they've done you know whether it'd mean
they might they might have they might
have created a technology based entirely
entirely on their atmosphere and their
planet it might be just a different way
of propulsion a different way of
organisms different way of everything
yeah there's so many possibilities it
could be swords drips that's destined
that's the power like rips like those
are humans I read something somewhere
about the possibility of there being
living creatures in other parts of the
universe that are made out of light
that's that's what I mean like yeah it's
like what are the parameters for
something being alive with given all the
different possible environments in the
universe like what I know about life is
like what life we've ever discovered on
earth like maybe life can exist and
bizarre crazy environments just a
different light like that cocoon like a
different kind of life I mean like that
movie cocoon who's like old people and
then they got young yeah if I can but
but the thing was it came and they look
they look cool in the spirit like a lie
he became like a life I don't remember
that enough I do remember though account
I remember it was old people and they
they turn young and start [ __ ] yeah a
big part of it yeah yeah yeah but will
you look at it from a but if there is
like other kinds of life forms out there
because it's just like a liar and it's
like a light whoa telly I forgot about
this and if we thought about they
thought about this long time ago man Wow
cocoon way ahead of his time
man Navi was just some shrooms back
there oh for sure that's what you see
when you're high as [ __ ]
come on I'm telling you that's why I'm
telling you you gotta watch that again
the ice is melting
that thing give me that photo give me
that phone man the shower made me
realize the earth is getting too warm
sexual diseases are ravaging your
population you have to stop you have to
slow down you're headed to the edge of
the cliff humanity is in great danger
you're pulling all the fish out of the
ocean you're heating up the sky and
filling it with particulates very air
you breathe there's not much time left I
see the boy with it ma'am telly look at
that thing
[ __ ] that whatever that thing is I don't
want it in me that's what I'm saying
like that's that movie there was like 30
years and wasn't it like 30 years ago
long time ago so that was 30 years ago
that mean they'd been new yeah about
what we just couldn't two and two
together I think the light thing was
just a physicist was speculating about
the possibility of different for he was
right yeah he was right so just think
that might be like what you said that
theory was with the light we might just
be little lights of all so how hard
would it be for aliens to make fake
people to move amongst us they could
travel here from other planets why can't
they make fake people that can wander
around yeah [ __ ] how many people do you
think you know that are aliens Donald
Trump
you don't give no [ __ ] about humanity
down here you know give no [ __ ] maybe
he just knows the spaceships are coming
yeah if you were president and they told
you spaceships are coming what the [ __ ]
do you tell people hey it's over now you
get the drone you get a droid like you
and you be on that spaceship
and let let people do what they do and
piss them off let them get mad at each
other kill each other that be a million
I think if aliens did show their face if
there was like a real bona fide alien
invasion or at least alien landing it
would be real similar to how we change
in terms of the way we look at ourselves
in humanity real similar to a natural
disaster
you'd be humbled we would all be like oh
[ __ ] like of a real spaceship landed and
real aliens are on board the station I
don't know let's still think the
government [ __ ] that's where the
government doing something that's true
that's true to some people you given you
given humans way too much credit
we stupid for the most part as a whole
yeah some people definitely think it was
fake yes the way it was fake it would be
real hard to convince someone that it
wasn't fake man people God could come
down here say as me as God we wouldn't
believe it we would believe like we
don't we don't believe nothing that we
ain't really seen the phone you know how
humans are we stupid well that's where
the whole flatter thing comes from right
all right I've never seen it yeah you
know it's like you know what's so stupid
about that it's like if you really felt
like that why don't you just get in the
boat and go to the end like wouldn't
that make sense like you'll be the
Christopher Columbus of this [ __ ] if you
want to be so sure and tell everybody
they wrong get your ass in the boat and
go to the end yeah that you really feel
that [ __ ] smart that is just
stupid like it's it's the dumbest [ __ ]
ever well it's weird too because they
dismiss all of the evidence that the
earth is round but yet they show no
evidence that's what I said so prove me
it's it that's what whoever listened
this get in the boat it's just ride ride
ride ride alright until you get to the
end and when you get to be in take a
picture and put it on Instagram and send
it to me but the thing is in the war
engine if you say that there's someone
like you don't
you've never done Flat Earth research
there are those photographs they have
been definitely doing video live do it
live do it live you do it live so we can
know for facts
oh and I'm gonna be up an Instagram
headquarters so I can make sure this is
really VI e [ __ ]
just a nice wall very tough to get
through whatever is there go there go to
the ice wall
just give me one picture send me one
good picture what it looks like Thanks
that's oh yeah I can do it well you see
if you go further with this they think
that stars are fake they do they think
that the Sun is way closer than it and
then we've been told how do they explain
how do you explain the Sun actually
going from from Sun up to Sun down
curving like that how do they explain it
we there's a very logical explanation
used to understand the science explain
that [ __ ] is I can't they stupid
hard to be there's gonna be people who
tell you that something's not real no
matter what it is it doesn't matter if
it's people have water in their bodies
it's gonna be a guy out there well
actually there's no water in human
bodies the water that you drink is
immediately evaporates through the
surface of your skin in an incredible
pace so reason why you're so warm you're
at ninety six point five degrees
instantaneously the myth starts forming
and you disappear you don't actually
drink water there's someone out there
that will tell you that there's someone
out there that will tell you that human
beings can live off of air there's dudes
that think that their guru lives off air
and he hasn't had food or water for
years there's people that are just dumb
man that's cuz wee boy when you boil it
you start thinking a stupid [ __ ] and
thinking you know what you're talking
about
didn't did it too
[Applause]